nos piden que simplificamos el logaritmo
en base 5 de 25 elevado la x entre 10 y
aquí voy a utilizar varias las
propiedades de los logaritmos que ya
hemos venido repasando durante varios
vídeos y voy a utilizar las propiedades
los logaritmos que tienen que ver con la
potencia y con la división pero lo
primero que quiero utilizar es esta
propiedad que tengo aquí que dice que el
logaritmo en base x de a / ven esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el logaritmo en
base x de am - el logaritmo en base x
debe menos el logaritmo en base x de 20
por lo tanto esto lo podemos poner de la
siguiente manera déjenme cambiar de
color el logaritmo en base 5 de 25
elevado a la x entre james lo podemos
escribir utilizando esta propiedad de
los logaritmos como el hogar en un base
5 de 25 elevado a la x menos logaritmo
en base 5 de bien muy bien acabo de
utilizar la propiedad de los logaritmos
que tiene que ver con la diferencia de
logaritmos ahora no voy a fijar en esta
parte que tengo aquí dice el logaritmo
en base 5 de 25
elevado la equis y yo sé una propiedad
de los logaritmos que dice lo siguiente
el lugar es un base x de ha elevado a la
vez es b veces
el logaritmo en base x de a la potencia
pasa multiplicando en un inicio el
logaritmo y entonces yo puedo escribir
esto de la siguiente manera esto es
exactamente lo mismo que x veces el
logaritmo en base 5 de 25 lo único que
hice fue pasar la potencia multiplicando
ya esto no olvidemos restarle el
logaritmo en base 5 de 10 y bueno a
continuación lo que quiero que veas es
esta parte de aquí el logaritmo en base
5 de 25 se puede simplificar porque esto
de aquí es lo mismo que pensar a qué
potencia tengo que elevar 5 para que me
dé 25 y eso lo sabemos esto es 25
elevado al cuadrado es igual a 25 y
entonces puedo escribir esto de la
siguiente manera 2 que multiplica x voy
a poner el 2 primero 2 que multiplica x
menos el logaritmo envase 5 de james y
ya está con esto tenemos la
simplificación de este ejercicio